[Musique]
bonjour à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
votre journal de l'afrique à la une de
l'actualité de ce mercredi soir la cour
pénale internationale qui a rendu ses
arbitrages l'ouganda condamne à verser 3
125 millions de dollars à la république
démocratique du congo des réparations de
guerre 19 ans après la fin du conflit
au congo brazzaville de la prison ferme
pour cinq policiers ils ont été
condamnés pour actes de torture sur
trois jeunes hommes deux d'entre eux
n'ont pas survécu selon les familles
l'état est lui aussi jugé responsable
et puis à l'occasion du one man show m
coup de projecteur sur le combat des
pêcheurs artisanaux hambourg sénégal il
accuse les gros chalutiers étrangers de
vider les fonds marins
des réparations de guerre estimé à 325
millions de dollars la cour pénale
internationale a donc rendu ses
arbitrages et déclare l'ouganda à
coupables d'ingérence dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo c'était
en
1998 kampala jusqu'en 2026 pour
s'acquitter de cette somme les
précisions depuis la sève de stéphanie
maupas
toute la question va être maintenant de
savoir si l'ouganda va s'acquitter de
cette facture les juges ont donc imposé
un calendrier un ils ont demandé à
l'ouganda de payer tous les ans le 1er
septembre une partie de la somme à 65
millions de dollars et ce jusqu'en 2026
et si l'ouganda devait ne pas
s'acquitter de cette dette est bien des
intérêts de 6 % annuels 1 seront
imposées à l'ouganda et puis les juges
ont aussi voulu veiller à ce que les
victimes bénéficient bien de ces
dommages là ils ont donc rappelé à la
république démocratique du congo qu'au
cours des audiences et bien kinshasa
avait expliqué qu'un fonds pour les
victimes de cette seconde guerre du
congo avait été créée et les juges ont
donc demandé que ce fonds puisse être
contrôlée par la société civile
congolaise mais aussi par des experts
extérieurs voilà ce qu'on peut dire de
ce jugement aujourd'hui 3 3 325 millions
de dollars doivent être payés pour les
dommages causés par l'ouganda pas la rdc
les autorités de la république
démocratique du congo justement qui
n'ont pas encore réagi neufs payants au
moins sont impliquées dans cette guerre
leur honda notamment mais la cour pénale
internationale
s'estimant incompétente pour juger
kigali ce conflit aura duré cinq ans 400
mille civils ont été tués à des pillages
ont également été dénoncés par kinshasa
des précisions d'accessible
325 millions de dollars c'est le montant
des réparations fixée par la cour
internationale de justice à l'ouganda
qui devra être payée à la république
démocratique du congo qui réclamaient l
11 milliards de dollars ce montant
correspond à l'évaluation des dommages
infligés aux personnes et aux biens lors
de la deuxième guerre du congo entre
1998 et 2003 en particulier l'invasion
puis l'occupation par l'armée ougandaise
de la province de l'ituri au nord est du
pays kinshasa affirme que 400 mille
civils ont perdu la vie en raison de
l'occupation ougandaise et que six cent
mille personnes ont été déplacées dans
ce montant de 325 millions de dollars
figurent aussi les réparations pour le
pillage des ressources
l'exploitation des forêts ou la
destruction des parcs naturels en 2005
la cour internationale de justice
l'organe judiciaire de l'onu chargé de
régler les litiges entre états jugent
que l'ouganda doit payer des réparations
à la rdc les deux pays doivent alors
trouver un accord sur le montant de la
facture dès le début de la procédure
l'ouganda conteste le montant chiffré
par kinshasa estimant que son pays
n'était pas seules impliquées dans cette
guerre et que la facture est trop lourd
les positions irréconciliables des deux
pays font durer la procédure d'audience
en audience inaboutie ou reporter les
choses ont traîné en longueur jusqu'en
2021 lorsque les deux parties présentent
enfin leur demande à la cour pour qu'un
arbitrage soit enfin rendue
triste décompte à madagascar à nouveau
bilan officiel a été rendue publique
quatre vingt douze personnes au moins
ont péri après le passage du cyclone
bats hirai c'est surtout l'est de l'île
le district d'ikongo qui a pu durement
été touché des dizaines de milles
maisons se sont effondrées à des ong se
mobilisent le gouvernement également de
la nourriture des couvertures et des
produits d'hygiène ont été distribués
est les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines même seront particulièrement
difficiles
d'importantes récolte de riz ont été
détruites
de la prison ferme pour cinq policiers
verdict rendu à brazzaville au congo les
agents ont été condamnés pour actes de
torture sur trois jeunes hommes deux
d'entre eux n'ont pas survécu selon
leurs familles à l'image avait fait le
tour des réseaux sociaux les précisions
de rosie piotte pour france 24
le jugement est de 10 ans
d'emprisonnement ferme pour les quatre
policiers accusés de torture sur
plusieurs personnes sous un viaduc de
brazzaville en plein jour début janvier
une vidéo dans laquelle on voit les
policiers munis d'un marteau frappe et
sur les jambes de trois jeunes hommes
avaient fait le tour de réseaux sociaux
et conduit à l'arrestation des
responsables
au cours du procès on a appris que c'est
celle des tortures c sont en réalité
dérouler sur plusieurs mois entre
octobre 2021 et janvier 2022 et on fait
au total neuf victimes au total oui
jeunes sont aujourd'hui affirme à cause
des tortures et supplie subi deux jeunes
sont morts c'est dans la société civile
mais la justice n'a évoqué qu'un seul
décès l'état congolais est jugée
responsable des actes commis par ces
agents de force de l'ordre il a été
condamné à verser 30 millions de francs
cfa soit 45 mille euros à chaque victime
encore en vie et 20 millions de francs
cfa soit 30000 euros à la famille de la
victime décédée
l'avocat des familles des victimes s'est
dit satisfait il espère que ce procès
servira d'exemple pour les agents de
force de l'ordre
au nigeria maiduguri précisément des
milliers de civils pris à quitter les
camps de déplacés dans lesquelles il
avait trouvé refuge pendant des années
après avoir fui leurs maisons et leur
village cible d'attaqués djihadistes de
les autorités ont l'intention de fermer
ses camps de déplacés d'ici 2026 jacques
pellegrin nous en dit plus
beaucoup d'entre eux attendait ce jour
avec impatience celui du retour à la
maison chassés de leurs terres par la
menace djihadiste les autorités
nigérianes les invite aujourd'hui à
rentrer
énorme je suis profondément heureuse que
nous retournons chez nous dans notre
maison ancestrale et j'ai prié pour que
dieu dans son infinie miséricorde et
sagesse nous accorde la paix éternelle
des relocalisations fortement encouragée
par le gouvernement qui souhaite fermer
tous les camps d'ici 2026 à maiduguri
sur 13 camps existants sept ont déjà été
démontés ce qui représente entre 100 et
150 mille habitants les autorités
veulent avant tout de mettre fin à une
dépendance à l'aide humanitaire et
inciter la population à retrouver leurs
champs et subvenir à leurs besoins
pourtant de nombreux témoignages
montrent que plusieurs zones de l'état
de borno ne sont toujours pas sur et les
ong refuse encore de s'y déployer en
novembre dernier au moins trente et un
soldats nigérians ils sont tués dans une
embuscade djihadistes un risque que
certains sont prêts à prendre au moins
si nous rentrons que le gouvernement et
les autorités nous permettent de revenir
et de poursuivre nos activités
nous ne voulons pas être enfermé car
nous avons des familles à nourrir
si d'ailleurs nous n'avons même pas peur
de ces terroristes qui n a même pas peur
ou sans alternative dans un camp de la
ville les habitants n'ont pas reçu des
depuis sept mois
mais dans le reste de l'actualité sur le
continent l'union européenne qui lève
les sanctions imposées au burundi l'aide
financière avait été suspendue en 2016 à
l'époque le contester et président
pierre nkurunziza voulait briguer un 3e
mandat selon bruxelles il faut
maintenant salué les progrès en cours
dans le pays même s'il reste des défis à
relever
soixante ans après la guerre d'algérie
loup en france graver dans le marbre la
reconnaissance de la nation et la
réparation des préjudices subis par les
harkis et leurs familles emmanuel macron
avait en personne demandé pardon à ces
algériens qui avaient combattu aux côtés
de la france et qui avait ensuite
dû fuir leur pays après l'indépendance
leur accueil en france a été jugée
indigne
nouveau coup dur pour les jeux de la
francophonie une nouvelle fois reporté
annoncé pour 2022 en république
démocratique du congo ils ont finalement
été reprogrammé à 2023 si tout va bien
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie le relief invoque l'état
d'avancement des préparatifs mais des
soupçons de détournement de fonds autour
de certains chantiers semblent
compromettre l'événement
le coup d'envoi d'un sommet
international dédié à l'océan politiques
scientifiques entrepreneurs ong se
retrouve à bray ce temps en france
l'enjeu est de taille alors que le
milieu marin subi de multiples
bouleversements la pêche on est
considérablement affecté illustration
sénégal où les chalutiers étrangers
menacés des pêcheurs artisanaux
reportage de sarah sakho et lee van gaal
se sont rendus en bourse à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de dakar
ils font partie du paysage depuis
toujours les pêcheurs artisanaux de
m'bour l'un des plus grands ports du
pays sont aujourd'hui en pleine crise
ibrahima 36 ans est sur le chemin du
retour
comme très souvent la journée de pêche
n'a pas été bonne
je n'ai capture est que ça aujourd'hui
avant à ces pluies km des côtes on avait
beaucoup de poissons
aujourd'hui même en allant à une
trentaine de kilomètres on ne pêche
presque rien la pêche n'est plus
rentable en cause la surpêche
industrielle
les pêcheurs de m'bour accuse les gros
chalutiers étrangers de vider les fonds
marins certains n'ont d'autre choix que
d'abandonner le médecin
pape tuent le temps avec quelques amis
tous d'anciens pêcheurs
on a vendu la mer aux bateaux étrangers
il ne nous laisse que des miettes la
seule solution qui nous reste nous qui
connaissons bien l'océan c'est de tenter
la traversée pour le
le désarroi des hommes de moore
abdoulaye n'diaye le connaît bien cet
ancien pêcheur travaille étroitement
avec les communautés locales
aujourd'hui il appelle les autorités à
une gestion durable de la ressource à
l'iut
de
l'ouragan et des pays limitrophes et
publie
également des lieux mais aussi les pays
d'afrique et les méthodes comme le
dernier le burkina le mali
les pêcheurs ne sont pas les seuls
concernés par cette raréfaction de la
ressource halieutique
les mareyeurs les femmes vendeuses et
transformatrices de poissons sont aussi
des victimes collatérales au sénégal
selon es chiffres officiels près de 20%
de la population vit directement ou
indirectement des produits de la pêche
le second prix de la francophonie
l'innovation dans les médias remis à une
journaliste tunisienne la jeune femme
veut vulgariser le format du podcast
avec sa plateforme tunisien a podcast
dont france mais diamant de reporters
sans frontières et l'organisation de la
francophonie son partenaire les
diablesses eran riklis son talent à sa
rencontre son portrait est là je pose
des questions et en fait ces décès en
même temps de donner des conseils dans
la quiétude dans l'hôtel à tunis xabier
eder prend son temps pour faire son
interview avec son podcast redmen diffa
un travail propre elle veut faire
découvrir des métiers hors des sentiers
battus ce jour là c'est une humoriste
franco tunisienne tu as eu un parcours
le classique matériel à courtry
classique savoir que mes parents pour
eux ce qui était très important c'était
les études avec ce format d'entretien
intimiste cet architecte de formation
reconverti journalistes depuis la
révolution tente d'inspirer la jeunesse
tunisienne une jeunesse très touchée par
le chômage donc il ya un petit blocage
que j'avais envie d'explorer ensemble
avec cette jeunesse là et leur montrer
effectivement alors un qu'on peut faire
une reconversion à tout moment et 2 qui
avait des nouveaux métiers à explorer et
qu'on y arrive et pas forcément par un
circuit académique classique d'autres
podcast de rabia comme celui intitulé ma
vie en vf lui ont permis d'explorer le
rapport à la francophonie souvent
malmenés depuis le soulèvement de 2011
pour elle il s'agissait au contraire de
montrer la diversité et la richesse
culturelle du pays j'ai compris qu'il y
avait plusieurs rapports aux fêtes à la
langue française et plusieurs rapports
évolutif sur tout et donc il fallait
réfléchir
je j'ai voulu inviter des gens de
plusieurs domaines alors j'ai l'artiste
j'ai le franco tunisien qui vit en
tunisie
raouya est aussi chroniqueuse cultures
et sociétés à la radio nationale
tunisienne mais si la journaliste aime
ce média la radio ne permet pas
d'explorer tous les thèmes qui lui
tiennent à coeur
contrairement aux podcasts bien plus
personnel ça permet aussi parfois de
traiter des sujets plus complexes des
sujets tabous des sujets
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude d'écouter dans
des radios classiques son prix de
l'innovation dans les médias va lui
permettre de développer une plateforme
de production et de diffusion de
podcasts tunisien hébergé ainsi plus de
contenu et faire entendre de nouvelles
vous et sachez que le premier prix a été
décerné aux médias et les uns rdc basé à
goma vous en parlera demain dans votre
journal de l'afrique ainsi s'achève
cette édition on se retrouve dans 45
minutes pour un nouveau journal d'ici là
restez avec nous l'information continue
[Musique]